pan on start toasting those spices to
keep the pan nice and low cubing very
aromatic very fragrant and it's almost
like a live spice next nice little
coriander seeds coriander in now I'm
gonna get a bit of heat in the chutney
mustard seeds or smaller than coriander
seeds that's so much more powerful
mustard seeds in now curry leaves they
don't actually smell much dry but the
flavor they give off is extraordinary
Cody's in winning afterburner
otherwise you'll have that bitter taste
across the chutney keep the gas nice and
low the secret is sort of toasting so
releases that oil and intensifies the
spice touch of salt and then cup a small
powerful chillies keep them whole no
one's gonna eat them but it gives that
real nice burst of heat now let them
toast gently there one other chop the
onion we're gonna grate it why because
it sort of breaks down a really nice
puree in the chutney when you grate it
hold the root in the palm of your hand
and just push nice long great one of
those nice long shards look I've almost
got a nice sort of onion puree but it's
nice and clear a touch of olive oil
spices nicely toasted onions in
[Music]
between I suppose the garlic lightly
crushed on
play it nice and flat and just slice the
guy nice thin slices garlic in
taking your time to get the owners
caramelized beautifully will really reap
rewards in the long run tamarind paste
the sugar in the sugar first to be nice
tablespoons of sugar that will give very
nice syrup effect it sort of nice rich
syrupy texture to the chutney tamarind
paste you can get tamarind paste in most
delis and the big supermarkets it's
really nice
Fignon Asian but it gives that tartness
to chutney and it's sort of rich sugary
spicy next in with my coconut add four
nice tablespoons that will give a nice
body and a really nice texture to the
chutney
cut that coconut out and now and the
carrot grated the carrot just gives the
chutney nice sort of punish but also
helps to sort of come down the spice
carrots in the water comes out the care
flavors the Charlie beautifully but
gives that nice sort of vibrant bright
color to it as well and grating it
almost sort of it cooks instantly but I
want to get a texture through here turn
down the gas and just let that simmer
for five minutes if the carriers are
that moist and juicy then cover
tablespoons of water in there to help it
along now just five minutes
just as those carrots they'll go nice
and soft don't overcook them doing that
nice texture in there slightly spicy it
slightly sweet guess off keep those
chilies in there for that beautiful nice
and gooey delicious and ready to go in
his jar as that sits in the fridge just
gets better and better and better I love
to eat this chutney with cold meats or
even cold fish but with ham it's amazing
it's a really nice way of lighting up
the ham just sort of roll it up
get a nice spoon of chutney I mean it
looks fantastic
chutney onto the plate and serve and
that is a nice little gem in the fridge
but it's worth prepping in advance for
[Music]